oh can I just get on this out of the way
bro yeah I have some resentments not
towards you yeah but toward the
community okay I'm gonna so anyway um
what happened well yesterday was my
birthday
so over the weekend you know we me and
bad friends we did some shows we were in
um
uh one of them Columbus one of them
places yeah no we were in Pittsburgh bro
oh yeah yeah
so we're doing a show damn it
sorry it's Pittsburgh boy thanks
mom's gonna get your Playboy
subscription what is that Pittsburgh
yeah if you come down from there all
right all right anyway we're in
Pittsburgh we're doing a show half her
doing the show it's my birthday right so
then um Andrew goes um yo dude happy
birthday Andrew Santino from Bad friends
your co-host
I'm just making sure everybody knows who
you're talking about
yeah man we didn't say his name he said
Andrew yeah but I said it back anyway oh
yeah Andrew Santino okay okay so then he
goes um
you know we have happy birthday I got a
birthday collage of people sending in
you know I mean videos oh yeah and I
want to say bro thank you so much you
sending a video dude thank you a lot of
people did John Mayer did wow yeah not
the musician you know that I know got
him John was a mayor at Victorville oh
yeah no the musician that was a bad joke
but John Mayer did right Whitney
Cummings right the little handsome dwarf
he's in the movies what's his name uh
the handsome tour of uh Divine no way
yeah dude wow one of the best looking
dwarves I've ever seen better than Peter
Dinklage oh yeah they're not acting
similar but it's just a good looking
dude oh my god dude Divine versus
Dinklage dude that's a show dude or
movie or something yeah it's like Alien
versus Predator
he's got on him
that's got to be annoying yeah he won't
say that all the time yeah so there was
a bunch of people sent in videos oh man
except and then afterwards I I looked at
Andrew and go who didn't send one
you know because he requested a lot
I don't want to call anybody out man but
there's a couple that I don't want to
say their names but it really broke my
heart man
let me got requests
and they never sound one can I guess who
someone could be I can give you some
hints okay one hand yeah
one of the guys imagine finding a dead
body in a leg but it's been there for a
month and it's bloated oh yeah it will
be bloated yeah yeah some of the jewelry
too will be like yeah yeah so that's one
of them okay the other one
used to look like that
what Bert
I'm not gonna answer that man
okay the other guy is friends with the
dead body guy who used to look like that
but doesn't and he claims he's hispanic
but you don't see no Hispanic Bloodlines
in his face you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah he's like you know definitely
never said that okay sorry never said
neither neither okay but those are a
couple of guys man that like I thought
they were like
my boys dude and they betrayed me a
little bit like you know you sent a
video was long
you know there were some people that I
don't even know that well that's in a
video yeah you know and you know it just
goes to show you who your friends are
man oh in this business
yeah when he says stuff yeah but you
know when we get emotional we do this
dude yeah yeah I mean so it's like you
know you think that like they're you're
you know you know those two guys you
know what they're like man you know what
they're like
in a war dude oh you do you ever see
Forrest Gump yeah
remember
the guy was the guy that lost his arms
and stuff oh oh uh no not Dan not Dan
Benedict Benedict don't know nope
he's not I'm not even talking about oh
yeah I remember when who's he saving
when like um for us was running and in
the Vietnam War he was grab he went to
go save somebody's life was that him or
was Bob it was the black guy Bubba Bubba
anyway that's a terrible analogy but
these two guys would not run back for me
in a war I feel like if you weren't an
iron in a war let's just make up a war
like okay the war the Serbian Marina
Graham integrated what's it called but
Wars are going to be sponsored probably
by different so it would be like the
like like Amazon
war of 2027 or something right and
they're oh you know what dude Amazon
versus the eskimos that's never been
done
there's not a lot of Eskimos I know but
still
if it's cold dude they might win
yeah I don't know it's an icy
environment dude not Hoth like Amazon
versus like who Amazon truck drivers or
something yeah yeah dude Amazon truck
drivers versus Eskimos I mean that could
be a good War yeah anyway you and I are
caught up in it oh yeah right my legs
are gone oh right I feel like you would
go
I think you come back for me dude yeah I
put you on my um on my back
you know wouldn't be on your back like a
backup backpack yeah
and oh this is my friend backpack yeah
yeah
yeah yeah what I would do with you dude
I would tie a rope to your neck but not
to hang you but I would drag you what it
sounds well all you have to do is you
put your hands with where the Rope is so
you can get some oxygen oh yeah it
sounds comfortable yeah yeah so and I
would drag you out my point is it's a
terrible analogies but my point is these
two fools probably wouldn't even save me
man wow said it really hurts your
feelings
a little bit wouldn't it hurt yours well
I think that if Andrew asked everybody I
don't know who he asked you know and did
a lot of uh were most of the did your
did anybody else make a video like did a
lot of your other comedian friends make
them all right I'm going to tell you
Bobby Kelly I know I'm okay right he's
from New York I've known him for a very
long time him and I have rekindled our
relationships I really love the guy but
yeah Bobby Kelly he's sounding one oh
right my brother obviously kalila
obviously and then who else is Whitney
Adam John Mayer
um
[__] you a bunch of fools yeah but you
know they they were just not in it you
know anyway would you neither so you
wouldn't be sensitive about it oh yeah I
think well it depends like on who they
asked and what was going on if these
people were if they've been ill if
they've been in a hospital if they've
been oh okay going through like a family
thing I don't remember how long ago
Andrew asked me for it I think it was
just a few days ago yeah that's what he
told me and he goes Theo responded so
quickly and that's why
thanks dude
no don't cry brother you know brother
don't cry that really hurt me because I
was so I was laying on the stage yeah
like just watching the video oh and I
got emotional yeah but then of course I
asked but anyway let's move on from it
but you know it's out of pocketed it's
out of pocket god dude and do you feel
like you're gonna how do you pay that
back to are you gonna hold a grudge
because it sounds like you have a
resentment
yeah I do a deep one and guess what what
I'm not gonna [__] with those guys for a
while wow maybe at least a month
one month huh yeah then one month off
that Bobby Lee yeah